[Musique]
votre campagne marine le pen a saisi
cette petite scène où vous répondiez en
quelque sorte à des partisans de
jean-luc mélenchon qui vous interpeller
dans la rue on regarde
à bas et merci non mais c'est très
gentil merci vous confirmez vous
confirmer ce que je dis en permanence
vous l'avez gay vous l'avez gagnée la
voiture nous nous vous l'avez vous
l'avez gagné que de travail à chaque
fois que des types creevy mélenchon ce
sont des français d'origine maghrébine à
chaque fois qu'est ce que ça veut dire
en fait marine le pen ya un vote
ethnique pour jean luc louis a voté il
ya un vote communautariste il ya un vote
ethnique et probablement même un autre
religieux pour jean luc mélenchon c'est
pas très étonnant puisque cet homme en
réalité ces faits une spécificité de la
régularisation de l'ensemble des
clandestins et on peut faire des
catégories comme la venue de rome abba
excusez moi c'est pas moi ce sont bien
les instituts de sondage qui ont
démontré que 93% des musulmans avaient
voté pour françois hollande c'est pas
marine le pen qui a commandé le sondage
un bon alors il faut s'assumer soit on
en fait ça on n'en fait pas moi je vous
dis que monsieur mélenchon surf sur un
vote qui est un vote ethnique
communautariste religieux parce que il
s'apprête à accorder tous les droits
possibles et imaginables y compris
d'ailleurs aux clandestins et bien moi à
cela je réponds les nôtres avant les
[Musique]